- [Narrator] In upstate New York
there are two guys creating some dangerous
and risky explosions.
All in the name of science.
(dramatic music)
This is Ingo.
- I am Ingo Sonder.
I work for the Center
for Geohazard Studies
at the University of Buffalo.
- [Narrator] And this is Andrew.
- My name is Andrew Harp.
I am a PhD student at the
University of Buffalo.
- [Narrator] They are researchers studying
large scale disasters,
more specifically volcanic eruptions.
- [Andrew] Currently we
work on an experiment on
explosive magma water interaction.
- [Narrator] But there's a problem.
There's no lava in upstate New York.
So they made their own.
They start with rocks.
- [Ingo] 50 to 60 kilograms of rock.
We melt it in our furnace.
This takes four hours roughly.
- [Narrator] The rock liquifies
and can reach more than
2,300 degrees fahrenheit.
- [Ingo] We then pour the melted rock
from that furnace into a container
and into that container we inject water
and hope that the water
interacts dramatically
with our molten rock.
- [Andrew] It's almost
impossible without being there
to understand how much heat is
put off by this lava.
- [Ingo] I have to wear
an aluminized suit,
a jacket and kind of pants.
I have to wear that for protection
from potential splashes
and most importantly
from the heat radiation
that comes out of there.
We want to understand better
a magma water interaction
and that actually occurs
in explosive volcanic eruptions.
- [Andrew] The goal would be
to be able to predict
exactly the size and timing
of the reaction that we have.
I feel fortunate to be
working with something
that's so unique
that it's only done in a few places
in the entire world right now,
and to be at the forefront
of this research is great.